esta vez vamos a hablar de los
electrones de valencia y los electrones
que no son de valencia que se les conoce
con el nombre de electrones internos una
pregunta que seguramente nos estamos
haciendo todo este tiempo al observar
las configuraciones electrónicas es cuál
es el punto y el punto de la
configuración electrónica es que puede
darnos una idea de cómo un átomo dado o
un elemento dado podría reaccionar con
otros átomos y bueno para hacer este
punto más claro vamos a fijarnos en la
configuración electrónica de un elemento
que veremos bastante en química el
oxígeno cuál es la configuración
electrónica del oxígeno pausa el vídeo e
intenta encontrarla
bueno en un átomo de oxígeno neutro
tenemos 8 protones y 8 electrones
así que primero llenaremos el primer
nivel o la primera capa y después
empezaremos a llenar el segundo nivel
así que tenemos 2s 2 hasta aquí tenemos
4 electrones nos faltan 4 por lo tanto
tenemos 2 p 4 observa si sumamos todos
los electrones de aquí tenemos 8
electrones ahora si pensamos en cómo
puede reaccionar el oxígeno es
interesante observar sus electrones más
externos los electrones que están en un
nivel exterior y el nivel exterior se
describe justo aquí que es el segundo
nivel de energía cuantos electrones
tenemos en el nivel exterior bueno
tenemos 6 electrones por lo tanto el
oxígeno tiene 6 electrones de valencia
ahora cuántos electrones que no son de
valencia o internos tienen bueno los
electrones internos no son reactivos no
se involucran mucho en las reacciones en
este caso el oxígeno tiene dos
electrones internos
ahora porque son interesantes 6
electrones de valencia bueno porque los
átomos tienden a ser más estables cuando
tienen completos sus niveles exteriores
o en la mayoría de los ejemplos son más
estables cuando al menos tienen
completos los sus niveles
s&p del nivel más exterior entonces en
esta situación el oxígeno tiene 6
electrones de valencia muchas veces se
dibuja con una estructura de lewis se ve
algo así el oxígeno tiene 1 2 3 4 5 6
electrones de valencia entonces diremos
oye sería genial si el oxígeno fuera
capaz de compartir y obtener los
electrones más porque con eso el nivel
más externo estaría completo con 8
electrones el subnivel 2s estaría
completo y también el subnivel 2 p
tendríamos 2
y tal vez se puedan obtener esos dos
electrones de algún lado
y eso es lo que el oxígeno hace en
realidad toma electrones de otra parte
bien ahora trabajemos con el calcio
pausa el vídeo y piensa cuál es la
configuración electrónica del calcio y
piensa cómo es probable que el calcio
reaccione dado que los átomos tienden a
ser más estables cuando tienen sus
niveles exteriores completos cuando sus
niveles
s&p están completamente llenos bueno si
escribimos la configuración electrónica
del calcio usando gases nobles podemos
decir que es la configuración
electrónica del argón y una de las
razones del por qué un gas noble es tan
estable es justo porque tiene todos sus
niveles completos
el argón por ejemplo tiene completo su
primer nivel su segundo nivel y su
tercer nivel
entonces para formar el calcio además
tenemos dos electrones en su cuarta capa
nos queda el argón y 4s 2
ahora cuántos electrones de valencia
tiene el calcio bueno lo podemos ver
aquí son dos electrones de valencia y si
nos preguntamos cuántos electrones
internos tiene bueno solo habrá que ver
que el calcio puede tener 20 electrones
porque tiene 20 protones y por lo tanto
tiene 18 electrones internos que será
menos probable que reaccionen y podemos
preguntarnos cuál es la forma más fácil
de que el calcio logre tener completo su
nivel exterior bueno para eso tendríamos
que ganar 6 electrones así que tal vez
sea más fácil perder estos dos
electrones de valencia y este es el caso
en muchas ocasiones el caso pierde sus
electrones y se jong iza lo que le da
una carga positiva así que de manera
general uno de los beneficios de la
configuración electrónica es que podemos
pensar en que electrones son más
susceptibles a reaccionar
es decir los electrones de valencia en
la mayoría de los casos los electrones
de valencia serán los electrones que
estén en la capa más exterior de tu
átomo de manera general
si hablamos de elementos que están en el
grupo s o en el p podemos pensar en
cuántos electrones de valencia tienen
sólo con fijarnos en qué columna están
los elementos de esta columna tienen un
electrón de valencia los elementos de
esta columna tienen dos electrones de
valencia los elementos de esta columna
tienen tres electrones de valencia
cuatro electrones de valencia cinco
electrones de valencia seis electrones
de valencia y siete electrones de
valencia a por aquí los gases nobles no
son muy reactivos otra forma de pensarlo
es que son muy muy muy estables ya que
tienen completos sus niveles exteriores